STEPHANIE HANNON:
Healthcare.gov has taught us
that billions of
dollars is being
spent on technology
that just doesn't work.
It's not just health care.
It's food stamps.
It's the DMV.
It's our schools.
Code for America,
sometimes called
the Peace Corps for
Geeks, is trying
to address this by matching
software geniuses with US
cities to reboot local services.
We're excited to welcome
Jennifer Pahlka to the studio
today.
She's the founder
of Code for America.
And she also recently spent
a year at the White House
as the US deputy
chief of technology.
We're so excited to have you.
Thank you for being
a great friend
and collaborator to Google.
I think it'd be fun to
start by having you tell us
in your own words what
Code for America is.
JENNIFER PAHLKA:
Code for America,
as you said is the
Peace Corps for Geeks.
It was really
started, because we
were in the middle of what we
call the Web 2.0 revolution.
And yet, the technology
in government
is stuck back in the 1980s.
And that's a problem
for taxpayers.
As you said, we're
spending so much more
on technology than we should,
really orders of magnitude
more.
But it's also a problem
because when services
don't work, like healthcare.gov,
or like when you go to the DMV,
or when you try to enroll
your child in school,
you really have this experience
of not trusting government.
And we must trust our government
to have a functioning society.
STEPHANIE HANNON:
I'm sure you're
combating a lot of
perception with your program
that government can't change.
So I think hearing a few
of your success stories
or some of the innovative
technology that has been built
would be really great.
JENNIFER PAHLKA:
We see all the time
that while there's
great software
technologists and developers
and designers that
want to come help,
there are also
great people inside
government who want their help
and want to try
things a new way.
They know that it's not working.
So I'll give you
an example, when
we worked in the city and
county of San Francisco
last year with a
team of folks, who
were looking at the
problem of food stamps.
Now, there's a lot
of different problems
that happen with food stamps.
But they were particularly
looking at the fact
that when you enroll in
this program, most often
you fall right off of the rolls.
So you spend a lot
of time applying.
And then suddenly,
you're not on it.
And your EBT card, your food
stamps card, doesn't work.
It turns out that it's really
about a lot of very confusing
notices that you
get in the mail that
aren't written in
human language.
They're very long
and very confusing.
We enrolled in the program
and couldn't figure them out
either.
And so you haven't
complied with something
that they're asking for you,
some piece of information.
And they drop you off the rolls.
We ended up doing a very
simple intervention, which
was to text message people
when they're about to fall off
the rolls and telling
them to call the office.
And that meant that
40% more people
stayed in the program,
which is great.
So that's a lot of
money that we're
saving in a better
experience for the citizens.
But more importantly,
what we found out
is that the people that we
worked with in government
then understood the
importance of enrolling
in their own programs.
When they moved on
to new programs,
they said the first
thing I'm going to do
is sign up for it so I
understand the experience
that my users are having.
That's fantastic.
That means we have this whole
new generation of people
who work in government who
care about the user experience.
And they know the
technology is going
to have to change
dramatically in order
to have that better experience.
STEPHANIE HANNON: So you
talk about text messaging
as an important
channel, text messaging.
And I think a lot of
people in Silicon Valley
would jump to building an app.
Can you talk about the
importance of that channel
for the audience the
fellows are trying to serve?
JENNIFER PAHLKA:
Right now, we're
seeing that a lot of people
who need government services
don't have internet at home.
So if they're going to be
accessing these services,
it'll be possibly on a
smartphone, but generally
a low-end one.
And so it really has
to work in that format.
But very often they'll
only have a feature phone.
So a lot of what we do must
use just text messaging.
One of the first programs we
did in the city of Philadelphia,
for instance, was about
getting better feedback
on the city plan.
They were in the middle
of a very long term
plan for Philadelphia.
And they knew they needed
feedback from the citizens
about things like where
there were food deserts,
or which rail lines
needed to be extended.
But the people who show up for
the input sessions at city hall
tend to be not the
people who are affected
by the changes that were
going to be made in the plan.
So they knew that they had
this specific questions.
And they went out
and put posters up.
So there was a poster
in a certain area saying
where do you shop for your
food if it was a food desert.
Or in a bus shelter asking,
should this offline bus line
be extended?
Would you ride this line
if it were extended?
And the way respond is
to write back in text.
Well, you're getting
exactly the people
you know you're
trying to ask of.
And they're very
easily able to respond.
And that just changed
completely how they got feedback
for the plan in ways that are
so much more useful and so
much cheaper.
STEPHANIE HANNON:
A lot of people
are frustrated
with their schools.
Can you talk about
any fellow projects
that have worked in that space?
JENNIFER PAHLKA: In
our very first year,
we worked with Boston
public schools.
And we worked on a
really small problem.
But it's one that is
right at the beginning
of your experience
with schools, which
is selecting a
school for your kid.
They had just changed
the rules in Boston
about where kids could go.
And they had this 28-page
brochure with tiny, tiny type
that you were supposed
to read, and then
figure out where
your kid could go.
Truly, it was a mapping problem.
And it was about the distance
between school and your home.
And so we did a
very simple web app
that lets you type
in your address
and the age of your kid.
And it would tell
you which schools
you were eligible to attend.
And it really just
changed the relationship
between the parents
and the schools
where they really felt
like they were starting off
on the right foot.
Now, so much more has happened.
And we're working
with Rhode Island
this year to make sure that
when you start filling out
all of those forms when your
kid enrolls in school, that you
only have to write your name
and your address once instead
of 40 different times.
It's little things
like that that I
think are adding up to
people feeling better
about the experience they're
having with public schools.
STEPHANIE HANNON:
So your fellows
come from some of the most
agile, fast-moving technology
companies.
What's been really
shocking to them
as they've tried to work with
government, or big lessons?
JENNIFER PAHLKA:
Well, our fellows
come from a lot of places.
A lot of them come from
Google, which is great.
And we're very
glad to have them.
We would love to have more.
But yes, they do tend to be in
places that build stuff quickly
and have a philosophy of build
it and iterate it and also
measure it as
you're building it,
which is something that doesn't
happen often in government.
They are often shocked at
the level of risk aversion
in government.
We've done things like
trying to get data out
about the locations of
fire hydrants in the city.
And we'll be told sometimes,
oh, we can't let that data out
because it would be in the
hands of the terrorists.
Or right now, we're trying to
solve the problem of people
using EBT, that Electronic
Benefit Transfer cards, which
is what you get for food stamps.
If they use those cards in
places that charge a fee,
a lot of their benefits go
to a bank instead of to food.
And we were asking for the
locations of free ATMs.
And we're told, oh, that's not
data that we can make public.
Well, there's really
no risk to it.
And if you come from the
world where it's always best
to have it open, it's a very
difficult response to hear.
We really try to get our
fellows to understand
that it's a different culture.
And that they have
to work with them.
And that the public servants
that throw up barriers
to opening things are doing
it because they genuinely
believe that they're
protecting the public.
And you must tap into
that notion of service,
even if it's misguided,
and understand
that they have the same
intentions that we do,
which is to serve the
public as well they can.
STEPHANIE HANNON: I've heard
so many great case studies
in specific cities your
fellows have worked in.
And I'd love to know more about
how you make them sustainable,
and how you scale them.
How can you take a success
like Honolulu Answers
and bring it to a lot of cities?
JENNIFER PAHLKA: The
program that you mentioned
was in Honolulu, where they
tried to fix the website.
It was a very large,
clunky website
with a lot of information that
wasn't useful to users at all.
And they actually
used volunteers
in the community in a very
simple, basic interface
to rewrite the answers that
most citizens were coming
to the website to get answered.
And this was a huge success.
They pulled the whole
community together
to rewrite this website
in simple, clear language.
And then that spread now really
just through the community
to all sorts of cities
that want to do this.
And the city may or
may not participate.
In Oakland, where
I live, the city's
very much involved with it.
In fact, they host
Oakland Answers.
And the community is there
to not only write the site,
but keep it updated
and maintained.
Our Oakland Brigade-- our
volunteers that live and work
in Oakland in part of the Code
for America Brigade-- maintain
the technology, but
the citizens really
maintain the content in it.
We have this notion of for
the people, by the people.
It really must be
the people who come
to the table to make this work.
And that works in some cases.
A really great way that
Code for America technology
has been sustained
is through companies.
We've had seven companies
spin off of Code for America.
Textizen, the one I mentioned
that allows you to text message
the city about the city plan,
is now a very vibrant company
working with hundreds of
cities around the country.
Another one is Open
Counter that simplifies
the business permitting process.
It makes it so much easier
than it is without that.
And we're just now working
with a new company called
Transit Mix that actually
lets you mix and match
transit lines in
your city and is
being used by city employees.
When we build businesses
around these technologies
and allow people not just to
use them on a volunteer basis,
but to buy them as a vendor,
we can see really great growth
and sustainability.
But we've also
seen great success
where we've helped
governments bring
in the skills and the
talent they need to maintain
the technology that Code
for America builds for them.
And that, in some ways,
is my favorite path
to sustainability because
it means that you've
got people in there now that
are going to help that city make
far better choices in the
future about a whole wide range
of things.
And that's true
sustainable change.
STEPHANIE HANNON: I think
by now a lot of our audience
is wondering how they
can help or get involved.
You mentioned brigades.
I'll think it'll probably
be helpful to tell
a little bit more about those.
JENNIFER PAHLKA:
So we have brigades
in about seven cities
around the country.
And all that means
is that there are
people in that city who have
some degree of technical skills
from incredibly
talented technologists
to people who are just
comfortable using technology
but know that that's the
best way for them to help
make their communities better.
So they get together generally
Tuesday or Wednesday nights,
generally in city
hall, because they're
working with local government.
And they work on
open data portals,
or they work on
standing up applications
that help people
in their community.
And it is a really great
way to get involved
and to understand a little bit
better the problem that we're
trying to solve.
We always say, we the people
will solve this problem.
We also, as the people,
need to understand
how government works.
And often we don't
want to do that.
This is a great way not only
to understand the problem,
but to get to meet the
people in government
who are really trying to help.
So I would encourage anybody
to join their local brigade.
And there are several
in the Bay Area.
But also, if you live somewhere
where there isn't a brigade,
to start one and lead one.
That takes time.
But it's a lot of fun.
And you'll end up with
a community of people
that you really enjoy
and feeling really
good about the work that
you guys can do together.
There are, of course,
a lot of other ways
to get involved from the
highest commitment, which
is to go work in government.
We always encourage
people to think
about taking a couple of
years out of your career,
whether you're
spending it at Google
or sort of bouncing
around, to take some time
and apply to work in government.
There's some fantastic
positions open
where you really can do good.
We always hear from
folks that they
know that this will
make a difference.
They just need to know that
they have a real chance.
And there are now
so many more places
where you can go into government
and have a real shot at making
a difference than there
were several years ago.
And of course, the Code
for America fellowship
is a great way to work with
government, but through us,
which is easier.
There's a lot fewer constraints.
You're doing it for a
limited amount of time.
And you have a lot
more freedom than when
you're working in government.
It's an annual program.
And we'll be recruiting for
it again in a couple months.
STEPHANIE HANNON: Great.
So let's look at the
civic Open Data space.
I think there's been a
ton of energy around it.
But it hasn't realized
its potential yet.
And I wonder if you could
talk a little bit about that
and what could make a big
movement in that space.
JENNIFER PAHLKA: That
movement has been so exciting
for the past couple of years.
And it's been a lot of what has
drawn the attention of the tech
community to government
in the first place.
So I think it's had
success in certain ways.
And I think early
on, hackathons were
able to sort of show what's
possible in a way that's
sort of opened the door to
governments getting on board,
for people in
government saying, OK.
If we open this
data, the community
can build us an app that is so
much cheaper and so much better
than we would've
gotten if we'd done it
through a procurement process.
So, so many great early wins.
But because it is
hard to open data,
and because it's
hard for government
to understand how to
get that data open
with the characteristics that
will make it useful-- and you,
yourself, Steph, has said
it needs to be licensed.
It needs to be updated.
And it needs to be structured.
Well, it's one thing to open it.
It's another thing
to make sure that it
meets all those criteria so
that it continues to be useful
for developers, and
then, of course,
through the developers
for the citizens.
There's more that
government needs to do.
But there's also more that
the developer community
needs to do to
demand these things
and to help governments
do these things.
I think of one the
companies that we've
worked with through our
Accelerator program called
Captricity.
They can take data that's
currently locked in paper forms
and getting them into structured
data very, very quickly
through a wonderful combination
of OCR and Amazon Mechanical
Turk.
And they're getting huge
amounts of government data
into a structured format
so that people can use it.
They had a great
success in my time
in DC clearing the backlog
of adverse effects of drugs
at the FDA.
It took them six months to
contract to do this work.
And they had structured data
in their hands in six hours.
STEPHANIE HANNON: Wow.
JENNIFER PAHLKA: So the
tools really are there for us
to be able to have
this data available.
And, of course, when
you release that data,
think of what the
community can do
to help flag when there's been
a bad batch of some sort of drug
or some pill.
And the FDA can
actually act on that.
That's exactly the
kind of thing that we
need the community
to come to the table
and say, yes, we can make
this data unbelievably useful
to save lives.
STEPHANIE HANNON: So you spent
a year in the White House.
What was your biggest
learning there?
JENNIFER PAHLKA: I think my
biggest learning in the White
House was that we are at a
very unique moment in time.
I happened to be there during
the failure of healthcare.gov.
My boss was Todd Park, who
went off to rescue the site
and did so really heroically
along with the help
of many others,
many Googlers, who
worked incredibly hard to do it.
But what I saw
during that rescue
were policymakers
understanding that they
need the technical world.
They need geeks
to make this work.
When I was there, I was
asked to go start working
on the problems of
immigration because the people
in the Domestic Policy council
realized that if the Affordable
Care Act-- having worked
so hard to get it past--
was vulnerable because we can't
build a website that works,
what happens when we finally
get immigration reform passed?
Will the systems not scale?
Will we be at risk of
losing that policy as well?
That's something that
nobody wants to have happen.
But the good news
is now they realize
that we can't rely on
the ways that we've
been trying to do technology.
Sure, you can have
a vendor that's
going to tell you, no problem.
The site will work.
Well, they've been there.
And they don't
trust that anymore.
But they trust people
like Mikey Dickerson,
who came from Google
to help save the site.
They trust the people
who build technology
that does work for us
in our daily lives.
And they want them there.
And I think for the first
time they want them there
and they're willing to give
them the power to do it right.
And that's the first
time in history
we've been in that place.
So I just want us to take
advantage of that moment.
Since they want us
there, let's show up.
Let's be there.
And let's make this work because
they've never before realized
how important geeks are.
STEPHANIE HANNON: So digital and
technology people in government
is critical.
Do you think we're
going to see more
of that in elected officials?
JENNIFER PAHLKA: I think
that people will demand it.
I think the general
public is realizing
that if we can't implement
the policies we create,
we can't govern.
And if we continue to have
a political class that's
so disconnected from how
the world works today--
we just manage through software.
That is the reality.
It's not some other thing.
And if our political class
doesn't understand that,
they're not going to do a good
job helping run the country.
I think we will
increasingly see people
in bureaucracy and
in elected positions
with not necessarily
technical skills,
but with a fundamental
understanding of how
the digital world works.
That's what we need.
It's a difference between
knowing what's easy
and knowing what's
hard, and the difference
between thinking of technology
as something you buy
and something that you work
on in service of a user.
STEPHANIE HANNON: Great.
So if our viewers want to learn
more about Code for America,
where can they go?
JENNIFER PAHLKA: They can
go to codeforamerica.org.
They can go look at
our TEDTalk online.
And they can ask
other people that they
know at Google who've been
involved with the program.
STEPHANIE HANNON: Great.
Well, we're so grateful
you came today.
Thanks, Jen, for
your time with us.
JENNIFER PAHLKA:
Thank you so much.
It's great to be here.